und ich möchte mit einem Thema starten
was mich heute besonders bewegt hat es
geht um den
Menschenrechtsaktivisten Osman Kavala
der sich ja dreistet hat etwas zum Taxi
Protest zu sagen der als Oppositioneller
sozusagen gegen Erdogan stand dann wurde
er festgenommen bereits zum zweiten Mal
und ist jetzt seit vier Jahren in Haft
ohne Verurteilung und der deutsche
Botschafter hat dann darauf hingewiesen
wie auch andere Botschafter dass das
doch nicht so ganz in Ordnung ist und
was macht Erdogan er rastet komplett aus
und droht damit unseren Botschafter wie
auch andere auszuweisen für mich zeigt
das erneut dass mit diesem Präsidenten
alles möglich ist in der Türkei und ich
hoffe dass wir uns nicht einschüchtern
lassen denn das ist was momentan
passiert ich habe bislang keine Antwort
der Bundesregierung gehört keine Antwort
echte Antwort des Außenministers da
drauf tatsächlich hat man offenbar immer
noch Angst dass verloren und zum
Beispiel Flüchtlinge schicken könnt
ich teile Ihre These dass man die
Menschenrechte nicht mit Füßen treten
darf dass man da aufstehen muss man
geschätzter weltkollege Dennis in
türkischer Haft gesessen da wurde die
Pressefreiheit einfach verletzt und
trotzdem möchte ich ein bisschen um
Verständnis wir haben auch für die
Zwänge von Realpolitik und Diplomatie
manchmal muss man auch hinter den
Kulissen vielleicht was er wirken als
Politiker und es kann sich auch
kontraproduktiv auswirken in so einer
Phase dann öffentlich sich zu äußern
Realpolitik finde ich es so ein bisschen
das Unwort der letzten Jahre wenn ich
mir anschaue wie oft im Realpolitik
damit begründet wird dass man nicht
aufsteht dass man nicht sagt dass man
Erdogan zum Beispiel einfach machen
lässt es ist ja ganz sicher so dass die
Botschafter nicht auf eigene Rechnung
sich öffentlich geäußert haben in der
Türkei sondern dass sie ihre Regierungen
hinter sich gewusst haben auch die
Regierungschefs und wenn er jetzt droht
sie auszuwerfen ist die auszuweisen ist
die nächste Phase gekommen wo die
Regierungschefs sich miteinander
öffentlich äußern müssen unter stetig
Erdogan es wird schwere Konsequenzen wie
kannst du man könnte das doch machen zum
Beispiel oder sitzen heute beim
EU-Gipfel zusammen das sind ja nun zehn
miteinander verbündete Staaten ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob es alle EU-Staaten sind
das habe ich jetzt nicht mehr
nachgeschaut aber jedenfalls die meisten
sind es die können doch miteinander zehn
Regierungschefs sagen das ist unsere
Haltung und wir werden die verteidigen
und wir werden auch unsere Botschafter
verdrängen das kann Ihnen natürlich
trotzdem dazu bringen die Botschafter
auszuweisen dann müssen die Regierung
Handeln Caroline Bosbach wie sehen Sie
das ich wollte gerade genau daran
anknüpfen ich glaube selbst wenn genau
das getan wird und wenn wir auch diese
Herangehensweise forcieren ich glaube
nicht dass den das besonders
interessieren wird ich glaube wenn wir
uns hier empören und versuchen zu
moralisieren und unsere Werte zu
exportieren machen wir ja sowieso sehr
gerne geht ja auch für China ich glaube
drüben in der Türkei da fällt ein Becher
Humus um das wird ihnen einfach nicht
jucken und das ist ich glaube der Weg
dahin ist noch sehr sehr weit aus dem
politischen Receiver Herausforderung
aber für unseren Erwartungshaltung muss
realistisch sein und das allerwichtig
das eben auf internationale Bühne zu
machen zusammen zu stehen jetzt ist ja
auch ein Signal nach außen ich befürchte
mehr als eine Signalwirkung wird es
nicht sein also ich bin der Meinung dass
wir erstmal anfangen müssen über unsere
Drecksarbeit nachzudenken die wir
Erdogan machen lassen und das ist das
Thema Flüchtlinge deswegen ich finde es
ein bisschen schwierig wie wir überhaupt
noch den starken deutschen Mann machen
können während wir den shady Deal mit
der Türkei haben also das ist für mich
eigentlich wieder ein Fall wo ich sage
darüber muss man mal nachgedacht werden
was ja nicht so wirklich funktioniert
muss man sagen wo wir eigentlich schon
ich meine das ist für mich schon ein
Versagen von Frau Merkel sie hat ja
eigentlich einfach Erdogan ihre Arbeit
machen lassen aber das ist Drecksarbeit
das ist fürchterlich was da getan wird
das ist wie er das macht ist
fürchterlich das ist gold richtig dass
die Flüchtlinge in der Nähe ihrer Heimat
bleiben damit Sie jederzeit zurückkehren
können man muss nur
entledigt den Flüchtlingen wir hätten
genauso schauen müssen
das Geld fließt ja auch in
Flüchtlingslager und in die Ausbildung
von fl und so weiter das fließt ja nicht
in die Tasche von Herrn Erdogan das wird
ja überprüft dass man im Geld passiert
das ist einfach richtig also
das tun sie natürlich nicht aber
Drecksarbeit tut mir leid das ist mir
ganz andere Flüchtlinge sind müssen wir
vielleicht über einen anderen Diktator
noch sprechen Jan Philipp Burkhardt
Alexander Lukaschenko der die
Flüchtlinge Richtung Polen schickt jetzt
wird diskutiert heute auch in Brüssel
über eine Mauer die dort entsteht wie
ist das zu sehen ja eine Mauer da denkt
man natürlich sofort an Trump und ich
glaube es zeigt einmal mehr wenn wir
vertikal die Türkei sprechen dass wir in
gewisser Weise dann so ein Geiselhaft
sind und in einem moralischen und
praktischen Dilemma aus dem ich jetzt
auch nicht so einfach eine Ausweg
beschreiben könnte wir sitzen hier im
warmen Studio
Polen recht genauso wie die Türken dass
sie sagen so kann man nicht mit uns
umspringen nicht so nicht sagen also hat
sich ja schon an der an der an der
Grenze im Mittelmeer hat sich ja viel
geändert also die die Griechen schicken
ja aufgebrachte Flüchtlingsboote zurück
verschieben sie zurück was sie
eigentlich nicht dürfen widerspricht
eure Speck
europäischem Recht da guckt keiner so
genau hin weil alte Wissen das müssen
wir irgendwie pragmatisch lösen die
werden zurückgebracht in die Türkei das
gelingt nicht bei allen Schiffen aber
jedenfalls bei sehr vielen gelingt es
wir müssen uns wir sind in der macht
keine Drecksarbeit für uns der versucht
uns zu erpressen das ist die Wahrheit
wir machen keine Arbeit für uns
also das ist eine merksarbeit er hat die
Flüchtlinge gegen Europa geschickt um
uns zu erpressen die vielen Schiffe die
im Jahr 15 16 über das Mittelmeer
gekommen sind sind von der Türkei
losgeschickt worden die sind in Bussen
an die Küste gefahren worden weil
Erdogan ein Hebel gegen Europa
wir hätten sagen müssen wie viele wir
nehmen können wie viel ich Frau Merkel
dazu gemacht wir nehmen alle dann hat
sie ein Deal gemacht und in das
abweisend
weil eben heute viele sicherlich die
Bilder auch eben aus Polen gesehen haben
Bosbach was ist da weil es ist ja
eigentlich ähnlicher Fall wie in der
Türkei da geht es jetzt darum man
braucht vielleicht ein Abkommen aber wie
wir damals erlebt haben auf der
Balkanroute da haben ja die mazedonia
zusammen mit den Griechen auch einfach
angefangen Sound zu bauen damals noch
was ist das richtige an der polnischen
Grenze das wahrscheinlich genau nicht
aber nein aber so wie es auch gerade
diskutiert haben da jetzt die
Pauschallösung auf den Tisch zu legen
wäre mir jetzt sehr viel zu kurz
gegriffen es ist wir dürfen nicht
unterschätzen was das auch wieder
internationalen Raum in Europa bedeutet
welche Signal auch damit ausgesandt
werden auch was das im Ende wieder für
Deutschland heißt das einfach mal zu
Ende zu denken gerade auf die Folgen
wenn man unfassbare Migrationsdruck
draußen in der Welt mir haben wir dir
das sowieso viel zu wenig thematisiert
und wenn wahrscheinlich gar nicht an dem
Punkt an dem wir jetzt sind Stichwort
Bundestagswahlkampf all das was in den
letzten Monaten passiert ist das sind
Themen an denen man sich die ja wenn man
sich nicht die Finger verbrennen möchte
ja warum ist das so gute Frage ich würde
mir wünschen dass das genau das
Aufsammlung kommt heute ganz andere
Flüchtlinge als die die 2015 erlebt
haben die heute kommen im Flugzeug aus
dem Irak und aus Syrien hierher geflohen
Irak ist nicht mehr ein das ist kein
Kriegsgebieten und die kriegen eine
Ausreisegenehmigung ihrer Regierung das
sind auch wohlhabende flücken müssen ja
den Flug bezahlen da legen Familien
zusammen und die finanzieren die
Schlepper und Schleuser und fliegen
jedenfalls nach Minz das ist ja eine Art
von entschuldigung dass ich den Begriff
verwende von luxusflüchtlingen gemessen
an den elendszügen die sich vor ein paar
Jahren zu uns hingewälzt haben
du musst trotzdem differenzieren
und dürfen nicht von Flüchtlingen
heucheln wenn es gar keine sind das sind
überwiegend junge Männer die hier
arbeiten wollen in Europa kommen um ihr
Glück zu machen nicht nur aber
wir haben in den USA als Korrespondent
auch erlebt was sozusagen an der Grenze
zu Mexiko passiert wie ist das im
Vergleich der Umgang der USA und auch
die Diskussion dort im Vergleich zu
Europa also gerade die aktuelle
Situation ist ja sehr interessant denn
es sind ja jetzt mehr illegale
Einwanderer aufgegriffen worden als je
zuvor 200.000 jetzt in kürzester Zeit
und Joe Bein war ja mit dem Versprechen
angetreten die Grenzpolitik humana zu
gestalten und es gelingt ihm nicht
erhält jetzt fest an einem
einwanderungsparagraphen von Donald
Trump der sagt dass man auch ungeprüft
wieder die Leute abschieben kann dafür
kriegt das natürlich heftig ins Gesicht
jetzt von den Demokraten und die
Republikaner kritisieren ihn trotzdem
weil er die Situation an der Grenze
nicht im Griff hat er kriegt also Feuer
von beiden Seiten und zeigt wieder wie
schwer das ist die Situation Punkt
[Musik]